bonsoir ça va pas bienvenue dans
sanctuaire du désert
je me retrouve en face de Sylvain dans
le plus simple appareil vraiment une
vision qui ne va pas mourir l'appétit
moi j'ai extrêmement de pudeur le break
qui est encore plus jeune que moi et qui
a également un costume trois pièces
bien sûr en fait il y a que vous qui
êtes habillé comme comme je ne sais pas
comme un gauchiste
à descendre dans la rue là vous êtes
comment 68 CRS SS non c'est bien ça va
pas trop de courant d'air
ce petit gilet pour présenter la grande
librairie
ça vous plaît je savais que ça vous
plairait je savais que vous alliez me
charrier mais je sais que ça vous
plairait oui c'est tout ce que j'ai
trouvé l'intelligence à dire
quoi aventure aventure avec aventure
mais moi je suis nul mais alors toi tu
es nul qui est le plus fort des deux
dégage
moi j'ai mis ça dépend
technique pour se rappeler que les
signes n'aiment pas les règles donc on
ne dit pas si j'aurais aimé si j'avais
lourdeur x 1000 oh là là elle nous prend
vraiment pour des nuls comme elle a le
QI de Einstein donc elle pense que tout
le monde et en mode Beyblade quoi
[Musique]
je voudrais
moi j'ai rectifié mon français et j'ai
écrit ça dépend avec le C c'est dit
parce que je me suis fait engueuler 22%
c'est la hausse de la fréquentation de
la distribution alimentaire des Restos
du cœur sur les trois premiers mois de
sa campagne d'hiver par rapport à l'an
dernier c'est sûrement l'une des
conséquences de l'inflation et de la
hausse des prix en rayon justement c'est
le sujet c'est plutôt avec Agathe Godard
que j'ai eu des problèmes au cours d'une
bataille de homard au privilège
[Applaudissements]
ils se sont tout de suite bien entendu
envoyez-nous le Omar à la gueule Léonard
qui vous allez piétiner il y a des gens
dans la rue qui revient les bouffer les
homards que vous allez piétiner dans les
soirées de merde non mais François de et
là tu me fais une blague non il faut
être sérieux c'est ta seconde chance tu
es en cuisine aujourd'hui et tu vas
cuisiner comme ça non j'ai vu le tablier
Gladiator moi je suis venu faire de la
cuisine et pas un défilé de mode à poil
sa mission en décembre c'était
d'effectuer quelques travaux sur un
voilier hacké acquérir dans un port de
Saint-Martin aux Antilles alors que le
bateau a été emporté au large et elle
vise François ne sait pas naviguer il a
survécu 24 jours en mer 24 jours sans
moyen de communication de quoi perdre
espoir écoutez surtout de quoi il s'est
nourri pendant ses 24 jours en mer cet
homme a mangé du rat à cet homme à
manger des fourmis cet homme à manger
quoi d'autre
du cochon d'inde vous avez pas osé
manger du pangolin du crocodile en pâté
ah du crocodile aussi
en Afrique du Sud alors
soyez mixit top sur moi
on va dire que c'est un copain un peu
porte bonheur au fait par mon chef mon
mentor hervin Durand en fait gros c'est
le 6e de sa famille mais après je les
enterre bien qui font de la CB
tu vois la célèbre marque de ketchup
avait même promis de lui offrir un
nouveau bateau et ça a marché avec le
concours d'internaute ça a fonctionné
merci internet on a retrouvé Elvis merci
internet vous nous avez trouvé aider à
trouver le mec du bateau de beau de Guy
seulement j'ai toujours pas compris
pourquoi il voulait lui offrir un bateau
parce que clairement au début de
l'histoire on explique que le mec ne
sait pas naviguer
sortie des cours fin du travail et avant
de rentrer direction le supermarché mais
pas forcément le rayon fruits et légumes
pour ces jeunes consommateurs on a un
peu plus stressé au niveau des études
forcément on a pas trop le temps de
passer une heure chaque jour à faire la
cuisine
[Rires]
je vais me régale mais en fait il est
sérieux de créer devant tout le monde on
aurait pu les bouffer en scred chaque
fois on est bien dans le grand test et
cette fois vous êtes avec du lait
d'ânesse alors oui vous avez vous avez
bon mais regarde-moi ça on est quand
même dans la région qui
fait on est dans la région du champagne
ah ouais les gars
ça te fait rire
il y a de belles énergies en forêt
un arbre je me dis mais qu'est-ce que
c'est que ça qu'est-ce qu'elle fait je
comprends pas du tout je puisse les
énergies ou maintenant elle va me
chercher un arbre je comprends pas
bonjour à tous c'est vraiment une vraie
première c'est pour moi c'est une
immersion ça fait trois semaines que
j'en parle autour de moi j'espère
pouvoir voir une vache en vrai tout à
l'heure et pour moi c'est un réel
événement enfin avoir une pâte j'ai
jamais vu une vache en vrai alors il me
semble qu'en voiture en allant à
Deauville j'en ai peut-être croisé une
mais de près comme ça d'aussi près non
mais peut-être que je prendrai une si ça
m'abîme pas trop les ongles vous êtes un
peu le neck plus ultra de la crème de
l'élite de la cerise sur le gâteau et
des candidats
et si je me permets de vous dire ça ce
matin c'est que c'est la journée
mondiale des compliments
dans la société il y a une femme sur
deux de plus de 50 ans c'est quand même
énorme vous avez 20 % plus et bien sur
les médias dans les médias elles sont
plus que 7 %. c'est pas du tout
représentatif de la société donc c'est
réel donc là je viens d'avoir 50 ans je
rentre dans le tunnel bientôt mais je
suis dans le même